ray dalio runs one of the largest hedge
funds in the world he's at davos right
now he recently gave an interview to
andrew ross sorkin from cnbc they were
talking about is cash trash is gold
something that you should own or drop
and what about bitcoin remember ray
dalio literally manages over a hundred
billion dollars he's always thinking
about various markets various assets
here's exactly what he had to say about
currencies gold and bitcoin one of the
things that you and i have talked about
a lot over the years is cryptocurrencies
and bitcoin and in the past year or two
it felt to me that you had shifted your
view about them a little bit and
actually got excited to think that maybe
bitcoin and others could get interesting
and i'm curious how you think about that
now i think a digital gold which would
be a bitcoin type of thing is a um is
something that probably in the interest
of diversification of finding uh an
alternative to gold has a little part a
little spot relative to gold and then
relative to other assets but i think
that we're in an environment that we're
now going to ask what is the new money
and so when i say cash is trash what i
mean is that all currencies will be
currencies that will go down in
relationships to goods and services and
we are in an environment where we're
going to be looking at what are those
assets what is the type of money that
you could move between countries that's
a medium of exchange and a store hold of
wealth bitcoin has made a tremendous
achievement over the last 11 years of
being admitted it's a tiny percentage of
my portfolio now this is fascinating to
see that the world's largest hedge fund
he's talking about that he owns bitcoin
it may be a small percentage of his
portfolio but he understands the nature
of having an international currency that
isn't beholden to any one country or any
one monetary policy that is run by
individuals or a single organization
bitcoin being that replacement for gold
digital sound money has a place in his
portfolio now ray's really interesting
because he's not necessarily going to go
drop gold he owns lots of gold as well
he also has access to a number of
different currencies but his ultimate
belief is that fiat currencies are trash
cash is trash as you've probably heard
them say now that reason is because he
sees over a long period of time that
various central banks around the world
are going to have to devalue their
currency so in a way they can handle all
this debt they're going to constantly
devalue the currency and so what you're
going to see is goods and services will
continue to appreciate investment assets
will continue to appreciate all against
these fiat currencies now bitcoin
obviously serving as a digital store of
value and maybe even as a medium of
exchange on a global scale that ends up
being a really interesting asset as ray
specifically said in the last 11 years
bitcoin has achieved tremendous success
but it still has a long way to go the
u.s dollar has been around for about 50
years and so bitcoin at 11 or 12 years
isn't that much younger than fiat
currencies but on a grand scale gold has
been around for thousands and thousands
of years bitcoin obviously is not going
to catch up to it anytime soon and
therefore what we are going to watch is
that there is going to be millions and
millions of citizens around the world
hundreds of millions maybe even billions
that start to adopt something like
bitcoin not because it's been around the
longest but because it has superior
properties things like its divisibility
its portability and its programmatic
monetary policy to see the world's
largest hedge fund manager talking about
bitcoin saying he owns it and talking
about the tremendous success over the
last 11 years it's pretty incredible and
i think that he's on to something